now to a tense situation in the Middle
East Israel and the West Bank were
rocked by violence over the weekend
including an attack in East Jerusalem a
Palestinian gunman opened fire on an
Israeli settlement they are killing
seven people Secretary of State Anthony
blinken is in Jerusalem this morning to
meet with Israel's new far-right
government and piaz tire is also there
the funeral of Eli and Natalie Mizrahi a
married couple in their 40s was
emotional and angry following the
deadliest attack on Israelis since 2008.
seven were killed on Friday after a
21-year-old Palestinian opened fire
close to a synagogue in East Jerusalem
Heim Cohen lives in the area it's
disturbing and it's shocking
and it brings to home exactly how it can
happen to anybody another shooting on
Saturday This Time by a Palestinian boy
who was just 13 left two men badly
injured
the gun attacks follow a deadly Israeli
raid in the occupied West Bank on
Thursday that killed nine Palestinians
including 61-year-old grandmother majida
obaid
the Palestinian death toll from
confrontations with Israeli forces this
month alone now stands at 35 in response
to the escalating violence newly
re-elected prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu and his cabinet described as
the most extreme far-right government in
Israel's history announced a series of
punitive measures targeting Palestinians
including forcing the families of
suspected attackers out of their homes
and Welding the doors shut as well as
potentially stripping them of their
citizenship rights a form of collective
punishment says East Jerusalem resident
Yusuf abutara
his family his mother his father they
have nothing to do with it
now secretary blinken's high wire
diplomacy also has a meeting with senior
Palestinian leaders who have severed
security cooperation with Israel
following that deadly raid in the
occupied West Bank amid growing concerns
this Vault house situation could spiral
into a serious conflict Tony
MTS tie up for us there in front of the
old city in Jerusalem MTS thank you very
much